hey everybody Doug Walker here uh first
of all I apologize if you see some
schmutz and stuff on my face I just came
down sharing some stuff for demo reel
which we are having a trailer for this
week keep an eye out for that uh but you
don't hear about that you want to hear
about paranormal activity for and what I
thought of it and if you should see it
you shouldn't see a blah blah blah best
way to always go about theses talk about
way I thought about the past films for
maybe this will be repetitious cuz I
talked about a couple times but I'll go
through a real fast
okay first film I thought was okay
mostly because I was sorry used to these
tricks and gimmicks I didn't think the
acting was that hot but at the same time
I liked that it was using these subtle
tricks and that people were getting
scared by it so I really like that I
appreciate it more than I sort of liked
it second one I love love the second one
I thought it was good acting it was a
good set up some really ingenious scares
good characters I believe the acting it
was a good story tied into the first one
great love the second one a third one I
thought was kind of like a mix between
the first and the second some stuff was
really good like really in Jesus and
other stuff it's like oh come on we've
seen this and all are these characters
really that stupid I'm so sick of these
same mistakes especially when they're so
smart in the second one for the most
part uh so I'm sorry I have in half with
the with the third one yes sir I have
some of the most annoying stuff but it
also has some of the most genius stuff
so I'm very happen happen now we got the
fourth Paranormal Activity for and first
of all I'll say if you didn't get into
any other movies any of the other movies
this one's not gonna sway ya at all I
think they sort of found their formula
and their serve going with it which is
kind of the problem with it is that you
are starting to pick up the formula but
I had argue we're picking up in the
third one but they're still adding some
stuff with it they're still trying very
hard to keep it pretty fresh and new but
it's tricky it's a very hard it's a hard
shanwa this finding footage scary film
genre yeah I guess that's what's called
I don't know what's called it's very
hard to keep that new especially with
something that's a film series like this
way
you know supernatural stuff is supposed
to happen you know you're supposed to
build it up you know that now the
characters can believe the other
characters because then they just either
run out of the house or whatever and
movie be over
so those games get pretty old but I
don't think it's quite as bad as like
say the third one because they do have
some likeable characters the girl in the
movie is very likable the two little
boys are very likable and well here I'll
go to the story real fast pretty much
without giving away do a you know I
don't give away spoilers or anything
this family in 2011 I think finds the
the there's these new neighbors across
the street and something happens to the
mother so this boy is very forced set up
this boy apparently has nowhere to go no
other family so somehow they hook them
up with this family the people next door
because he's already said hi to him a
few times and this kid this is one of
those great you know scary kids in that
he doesn't quite go too over-the-top
it's just the right amount of kind of
funny kind of scary you know it's kind
of like the Damien kid from The Omen but
he the kid fights just the right in
between I made the director goes for the
kid whatever because you know he does
the little scary looks and stuff but he
for the most part talks like a real
little kid except for the points where
you know he wants to say something scary
in which case that's supposed to give
you that what the hell was that or what
the hell did that mean
so it's just the right level I'm sure
some people might think you know the
kids a little over the top and we've
seen it but I liked him I thought it
went okay you know it was very close to
going over the top I thought a stroke it
struck a nice in between and this kid
comes over of course
weird things start happening you know
chandeliers start falling and things
start moving chairs start moving all
this stuff and from there I mean again I
guess I don't want to give too much away
except for some of the stuff you already
know what's going
happen you know the the girl is
suspicious so she has the boyfriend sent
of cameras and all the laptops or
recordings of the little web cameras in
all the laptops around the place that's
a clever way to keep track you know to
do a kind of movie like this because
there's only so much you can film
everything you know with the hand-held
camera I think they even say in the
movie like dude are you gonna film
everything too it's like you know pretty
freakin nice camera they have in this
movie - it's like film quality but there
is family so and yeah and another kind
clever thing is that this is a clever
tie and they they usually do some pretty
clever commercial tie-ins with this
movie you probably seen us in the
commercial with the yeah I think the
Kinect they put on the night vision on
the computers and on the camera and you
see all the little dots that surround
the room well now you can do a lot with
that and they do a fair amount they
don't quite abuse it they do just the
right amount of what you see what you
see moving we don't see me because
sometimes you'll see like bugs moving
ghosts and then you know what was that
what was that moving like that so that's
a lot of fun that's very clever
um but bottom line in the story is that
things are happening what's this kid
comes over and he's also sort of talking
to their son the son of the of the
family and the sort of manipulating him
but you don't know what he's saying or
what exactly he's doing so it's another
kind of a mystery um so with me again
it's sort of like criminal activity 3
where there's some stuff that's pretty
good and some stuff that's pretty lame
um but it doesn't quite go the extent of
paranormal activity 3 because 3 head
when it had stupid stuff it was so
stupid you're just like really you
didn't learn from the other movies or
you like saber knocked if 'ti to their
aren't you making for the most part
smart choices and then three they make
the same dumb ass choices in the first
one so they make some dumb choices in
here but they're not quite as dumb but
the downside to that too is they
at the scares are also pretty damn good
too
but they're not as good as three it's
like they don't go all the way they
don't quite push it to the extreme that
three did so so so sort of take that for
what it is I'm in my opinion you can
kind of call it paranormal activity
filler because it doesn't quite answer
questions it just raises some more and
yes so you know it is leaving it open
for another sequel but but here's the
thing
to its credit and I do get pissed off
they're not giving us more answers you
know that they aren't just raising more
and more questions cuz it's obvious the
first paranormal activity was supposed
to stand on its own and then the second
one it's like well okay now's a hit we
gotta make a sequel you know but that
could sort of stand on its own two and
then with three it's like okay these are
so quick to push out I mean I'm sure
they worked very hard on but you can get
them out so fast we gotta keep a story
going because we have a good you know a
little moneymaker here so I have no idea
if they know where this is all gonna end
but it is sort of like lost in that
every single time you say no you know
what I'm done with the formula I'm done
I don't want to watching or blah blah
blah they just give you enough to say
well now I got stick around so I know
what that is
and it's good at that but the failing of
it as well is that it needs to answer
some questions too I know it's weird I'm
referencing wasps because I you know
hate the ending of lost because I didn't
answer anything but lost would give you
just as many answers as questions every
time it would answer something it would
raise another question and this just
seems to be raising more and more
questions maybe one or two answers and I
think we need more answers but again
they they keep me hooked the ending of
this movie I'm just like well what the
fuck was that it's like well shit I
gotta see the next one I got it all you
know cuz that was a very you know what
the fuck epic you know even more than
the third one the third one can't piss
me off with the ending
I mean it so didn't give any answers and
really none of the answers you know
nothing's gonna be answered here from
the third one either which again can
fizzes me off too but it seems to be but
they're letting on with every film to
their credit that it's getting bigger
and bigger and I like that that's smart
it's showing it's getting bigger and
bigger you know so the next one's gonna
be even bigger too but you don't know
how so it's it's clever marketing I'm
hoping they have a good resolution for
it um so again I don't give too much
away because because they do try to
raise more questions within stuff um I
can't go as far as to say it's just more
of the same because some of it is it
definitely is you know what we've seen
this but they catch some of it too like
they dive in pretty early with with the
kid and the supernatural stuff they
don't wait too long
there are jump scares and there at first
they're not too bad you know because
it's like okay you know give it some
credit but then it's like you know you
got the camera there then the cat jump
side and we were with a crowd that
screamed at everything they can't jump
don't encourage them and my jump scares
okay they're cheap but when they do in
real scares in here they're pretty
effective um so I'll give you one last
example as to both the strengths and the
failings of this film before I tell you
who probably like it who wind um there's
a scene that's like Hitchcockian genius
suspense oh yeah yeah we'll give away
too much but it involves a kitchen knife
and something happens to this kitchen
knife and they draw it out for a good
period of time and you know that
something is going something else is
gonna happen with this kitchen knife and
you're just waiting for it and waiting
for it and it is such again I don't get
away because it's so good but it is such
an ingenious setup because every time
someone
you know gets close to this kitchen
knife you're going oh but here's the
downside the payoff is not good enough
and when they do give you the payoff
it's too early you could have held on
this knife pretty much throughout the
entire movie especially when you see
what happens to some other characters in
the movie I'm like you could have used
that plot point later and you could have
had people's stomach turning every
single time they're in the kitchen
and it could have made people just
cringe throughout the entire film every
time someone will go in the kitchen
but they do it wait they give it away
way too early and they give it away at
just the wrong point and they don't
really do anything with it and it's just
like oh oh
what an ingenious setup but that's what
I'm talking about is how it will have
some setups there so oh you know that
the Kinect thing was ingenious um and
there's a scene with a kid taking a bath
that I mean it's like that stuff that's
the stuff that scares me I mean there's
some the jump scares you throw some in
the beginning because you have to set up
story and he can throw that scares in
yeah so you have one or two little jump
scares I understand it I'll stop just
let the atmosphere build you don't need
to have the cat or cut to someone
closing a door and it's like that sound
is supposed to scare you you know it's
they get so lame so likes it's not as
bad as three with the jump scares guys
like there's one where like the woman
kind the classic with a mask I'm like
are you kidding me these are a little
are a little more clever but they're
still obnoxious so in terms of that who
are like this movie who wind I say if
you really like the Paranormal Activity
movies to see it I don't think it'd be
like one of your favorites or anything
but I think it keeps you guessing it
keeps you wondering what's going on it
has some returning characters too it's
not like just something from out of the
blue I mean that they got some character
come back I'm a Taemin for the most part
pretty cleverly but again there's a lot
of wait when did this how did that so
we'll see if it adds up
I'll be honest a lot of this depends on
what it's just like lost a lot of it
depends on whether or not they can
answer these questions as satisfying way
or if they answer it um but it I got to
do I'll see Paranormal Activity 5 no
matter what I mean it's like the fifth
one has to do something really really
bad to you know cut me from the movies
now which I'm not saying it can't it
definitely can I mean it can do
something right just yet you know what
fucking I'm done you idiots screwed it
up but they're they're keeping just
enough you know to have me come back and
sort of see this formula and stuff like
that if you want to see a great video by
the way check out bretzel flosses
paranormal activity was a guy I think
was like for MU ah and he just points
out all the stuff that keeps happening
in these films it's very funny and it is
the fault of the movies but they're
trying to get around it some work some
don't this is definitely not the
strongest but I don't think I don't
think it's the weakest either
I think it's stronger than three I think
I can even ever get stronger than the
first one so yeah people who won't like
it anyone that hasn't like day and the
other paranormal activity movies you
know if you've not afraid with doors
opening or chairs moving or you know cg
shadow isn't that you probably not gonna
be that scared by this you know this is
not gonna sway you I think other people
who won't like it if you're starting to
get fed up with just what the hell's
going on and not really getting them any
answers I mean this doesn't answer much
but again it keeps it keeps asking some
interesting questions about what's going
on too so it does have them but if
you're not interested you just want to
get some freakin answers this isn't
really gonna answer anything for you so
yeah that's my paranormal activity for
review
you can go check it out or not hopefully
this review has helped and I shall talk
to you guys later keep an eye out for
the devil real trailer later